and we are about to have liftoff in the
fifth game of the 5 minute plus 1 second
increment time control there's Yan naami
and here are the opening moves we have
Knight F3 from Magnus in this game so
instead of our E4 e5s and Petrov and
turning into frenches we have an
English exactly and here to move E3 an
interesting move by man I wonder what
exactly he has in mind in case yon plays
the move D5 perhaps he wants to play
something like Knight of C3 so let's see
what yon will do here can also go for a
setup with B6 and there we have the move
B D5 and now the move B3 by
Magnus and he's just trying to Fen ketto
on this long diagonal staring towards
the black king and in these positions
sometimes white is able to hand black
and isolate a Pawn on the D file but
instead we see D4 so we have the box all
these pawns staring at each other so
Benjamin in this opening do you like
black or do you typically like this from
White I think Black's doing pretty well
here C takes D4 is a nice move by Yan he
could take on C4 and after Magnus
recaptures play a move like A6 followed
by B5 and Bishop B7 and it's turning
into a bit of a queen gamit accepted but
I think black is a pretty reasonable
version the N of C3 is often a little
bit misplaced as it's blocking the
bishop on the long diagonal and very
often you would rather have it on D2 so
let's see what Y is going to do I think
this this approach with D4 and A6 is
very solid it's becoming sort of a
queen's gambut accepted type of position
and the big part of these type of
structures is that black has some weak
squares the C6 Square in particular and
we see the light Square Bishops coming
off and Rook to A7 play but I think
white should take on B7 put a queen on
F3 put a rook on C1 and D1 and that C6
square is tender and black needs to look
out for it exactly I'm a little bit
surprised by the move Rook to E7 by Yan
I think he would have also addressed the
issue with Queen B6 that's what he does
now but had he played Queen B6 on the
last move he could have already played
played Knight but D7 or Knight C6 and he
should be doing completely fine now
Magnus might have a move or two to
create some problems for y but if he
doesn't do anything quickly I think Y is
going to be doing absolutely fine here
with KN bd7 coming on the next move a
problem for white is that all of the
pieces look like they're in pretty
optimal squares you need to look where
to improve the Rook on F1 that's the one
piece but Rook to E2 that looks a bit
silly so maybe Queen E2 Rook D1
something like that it does feel though
as you said that black is in time so
good knight to E2 he's opening the C
file it's about that C6 Square
potentially and what do you make of this
yeah so we see trade on F3 I think
magnus's idea was that in case yon would
have played Knight B D7 there would have
been Knight C6 and that is why yon
traded first now he goes Knight C6 bring
his Knight into the game I think Robert
you've highlighted you've highlighted
this before Magnus is going to try to
apply pressure on that C6 Square he goes
Queen to C2 pressuring the Knight maybe
a knight to D4 jump in the near future
so Yan still has has a few problems to
solve here Rook C8 would be a big
blunder Bishop D4 would be a winning
tactic because the Knight is pinned to
The Rook so Rook C8 would not be a good
move even though it looks like a normal
one to protect that Knight Rook C7 is
possible because Bishop D4 after Rook C7
you can actually take that piece because
there are tactics on the E2 Square so
you need to time these things correctly
if you are both these players but right
now Yan needs to avoid any sort of
tactics that lose him some material oh
he walked right into
it oh my
gosh Robert you cannot do this you if
you're playing Magnus you cannot make
blunders like this oh my God we just
spoke about it the Knight on C6 is
pinned because of the back rank check
and Yan he looks up at the ceiling but
there is no Beth Harman Solutions here
he's unfortunately going to lose this
game this is just clean
material yeah he's down a very clean
exchange Queen B1 by Magnus now he's
just going to trade up some pieces what
L of blunder by Yan pesi he could have
just played Rook to C7 and then like you
said there would have always been these
tactics with taking on D4 and taking on
E2 but now he's done an exchange and
Robert I think he we've talked about
this before if you want to have a chance
against banges you cannot blunder like
this and you also you cannot just throw
games that was an even looking position
and now he is just down a rook for a
bishop there's an open file if the
position were a bit more closed maybe we
would say that black had chances of
course if he had a pawn and a bishop for
The Rook then sure but it's a clean
exchange Rook for Bishop there's an open
C file Rook C1 here looks very promising
uh Benjamin this should be a onesided
finish yeah 92 a nice move by Magnus now
he's just going to move a rook to C1
Queen C2 trade of the queens and you can
already pretty much resign here if
you're Yan palom she very unfortunate
loss that seemed I mean there was a
little bit of pressure by Manus but yeah
he just had some uh he just had to find
a couple of AC moves to solve all of it
it was just a caress move there he just
wasn't looking for tactics he was
looking for positional pressure and look
at this move Queen E4 Magnus even when
he is winning positions he continues to
be precise that Knight wanted to land on
C3 to close down the C5 maybe get a pass
Pawn now that Knight is pinned the queen
on B7 has to stay put tied down to the
C8 square and look at this maneuvering
you can trade on C3 if you want he says
no Queen on A6 protects it all E2 and A2
beautiful instructive play from Magnus
Carlson yeah great Stu here by Magnus
young goes Pawn to G6 he still he still
has that Knight on C3 I guess now he's
going to recapture with the pawn queen
D3 I think if Magnus gets the
opportunity he's probably going to give
his Rook for the pawn Rook C2 Magnus is
winning here but how do you actually
convert this Robert there there's still
some work to be done and I wonder if
Magnus has completely mapped this out
where he recognizes that certain end
games if he takes on C3 and even if he's
only at one Pawn in the queen end game
it's winning cuz he just has that kind
of knowledge but here in in this
position he might bring his King to help
out in the center Queen to C4 that takes
care of everything B3 will be defended
and that C3 Pawn it's going to be
surrounded exactly and now he can go
Queen to C4 King E2 and he should win
this game pretty easily so let's see
what Jan is going to try to do here
maybe King G7 moving the king up a
little bit there there's nothing black
can do Yan just has to sit and wait here
and wait for Magnus to show him how you
know this game is won now I think Rook
C3 is a good way to make things a lot
easier for white and there go just two
extra pawns over there on the queen side
this is one where if the white king
could be checked a bunch of times maybe
you have a chance but at this stage King
oh King E2 might actually have some
problems with the g2 Pawn being targeted
so it's not as easy as it would
initially appear
perhaps yeah still some work to be done
for Magnus he goes King E2 okay now I
guess Queen D5 likey pointed out for yon
hitting that pawn on G2 which is awkward
to defend you can go for the move F3 but
then there's Queen G5 although I guess
then there's King F1 so Magus should be
winning winning here in many different
ways even just A5 he goes F3 so I guess
after Queen G5 here he is going to go
for the move King
F1 yeah then you don't see too many more
checks even here Queen G3 check so what
king to F1 the problem is that the black
queen needs to be in three different
locations at once it needs to be on H1
but then also go back to G3 when the
King goes to F2 you just can't get
everything there White's pawns go up the
board Magus Carlson is going to take his
first lead in this match exactly B4 he's
just pushing the pawns up slowly but
surely King G8 yon just shuffling back
and forth there's nothing he can do just
perhaps just B5 here or queen D4 another
nice move offering the trade of Queens
but also attacking this Pawn on H4 and
if you take the pawn on H4 black never
has any Perpetual ideas anymore that's
true the king can slink away to the H2
Square eventually and you just block a
check on the diagonal so Magnus is up
three Pawns in a queen end game a few
checks that's about it so yand pom she
resign